foreign
[Music]
ERS so thank you it turns out the Rams
suck at football
I'm not sure what you're talking about
um well that's what the article is
I may or may not have been there live to
see it in person and then I may or may
not have left early
what what why would you leave early
um was a preseason game you don't you
don't get your ass kicked horrible yeah
did you guys see there was a video of um
Shane McCoy
yeah he's like they're in the street and
there's a fight and the thing is is they
both of them can't fight so but they're
trying to fight and so they're like
running away from each other they're
like hating each other tripping and then
Shady McCoy's on the camera going dude I
don't know what to do because none of
them can fight
cops involved now it's just crazy and
that's one reason why I don't want to
say NFL football players are fighting on
the streets no no no fans these are just
fans but but Sean McCoy's retired player
he just happened to be walking to his
car probably I assume but like I don't
like leaving after the game unless it's
like a tight game yeah
um it has to be worth it when you're at
the Super Bowl you want you waited till
the end I wait to the whole thing yeah
because people are drunk [ __ ] could pop
off Anything Could Happen dude you hear
Dodger games do like Dodgers versus
Giants all like either Stadium someone's
just walking by himself and they're
having this like five or six guys I'm
from the other team and they'll just
like jump him for no like no reason no
provocation like I don't need to be I
don't need to be that's really bad but I
also heard the parking at Sofi stadium
is 150 this is true oh my God okay so I
have a parking pass but like because
you're supposed to ten thousand dollars
no see it's not that bad to see the
parking pass is pretty like reasonable
relative to how much parking is so to
put things in perspective like 10 years
ago a giant stadium for World Series
parking was a hundred dollars okay 10
years ago 10 years ago right now for a
regular season football game
like even like before covid we're
looking at like 60 to 80 now it's just
like no big deal 100 bucks yeah 150
bucks like I'm talking this is like
right across the street so the further
you get away from Sofi the cheaper it
gets but you're still looking at sixty
eighty dollars you have to walk a few
miles no shuttle people have been
charging with their driveways right like
parking my driveway it's 40 bucks that
happens a lot and there's an app for
that it's called like spot hero or
something like that I'm gonna look that
up right now yeah I'm supposed to go to
a concert at so far oh and I heard the
parking is going to be 160 I'll I'll
like just double check the name of the
app so is it more worth it to just Uber
then or do the Uber rates also uh dude
just for it fortunately I think the ram
sucks you don't have to go to games
anymore
it's it's spot hero spot Heroes what
they'll do is they'll find you the
driveways there's a liquor store across
the street from Sofi they sell parking
that's where I park for Super Bowl it
was 150 you are the man yeah
and I take I tipped the guy 20 bucks
because it felt Shady you know like
because he parked me in a handicap spot
so I don't know if like cops are gonna
come by and take your toe I have no idea
so I was like hey dude here's 20. he's
like oh okay thanks man and then like
fortunately there was a valet there it
wasn't a valet it's just some guy yeah
was it owned by a Korean Uncle you know
I think the liquor store probably is oh
but the parking spaces but the worker it
might have been like the worker at the
liquor store
um but when you you inspire hero was
great is you can call them and then so I
asked them I go hey is there not gonna
attendant because what if someone just
parks there they're like no they
shouldn't I'm like well I can't go on
you saying they shouldn't I go is there
going to be intended she's like there
normally isn't but for Super Bowl I
think there will be that's like the
confidence is amazing maybe maybe they
just thought you were handicapped yeah
right I know it's like those Asian guy
he's handicapped give him that he's part
of the Rams Head on knowing he's handy
yeah
yeah so I was like hey what do I do
someone's there says you know what call
us call us I go what are you gonna do
we'll find you another spot I'm like
where yeah it's the Super Bowl like
where are you gonna find me a spot for
real she goes you know what I'm pretty
sure they're gonna be an attendant there
she's just trying to get you out of this
conversation she's like what do I got to
tell this guy so you're there last night
did you notice that the Rams had to use
the silent count at their own home
stadium on the night they hung up the
banner from winning the [ __ ] Super
Bowl last year they have to use a silent
count at home that's bad news for you
guys bud what's Silent Sound account
means that the if the offense like Matt
Stafford and the offense needs to speak
with each other well they have to use
signals now because there's so much
crowd noise while he's on the field but
the crowd should be shutting the [ __ ] up
actually but if because he's on the
field and the crowd's loud it means
there's not just homers there it's like
Bills fans too and that's a big problem
for you guys for a home field advantage
that doesn't exist anymore I thought
those guys got [ __ ] headsets in their
helmets and they can talk they do but
that those disconnected after for a
certain amount of time for the play and
it's not players can't talk into it but
can we hear so it's the coach calling
place the actually funny story before
before they disallowed that uh Randall
Cunningham was a quarterback and Randy
Moss was like a rookie receiver
and Miranda Cunningham is like six feet
tall probably five ten he can't see over
the over the o line
so the offensive coordinator would just
go okay you have Randy on a fly what
does that moved and Randall I can't see
him and fly Rod's just straight towards
the end zone it's a straight run Randall
and they practice this so Randall knows
where uh Iran's gonna be he'll just toss
it in the air and ready to catch a
touchdown the next season they outlawed
talking so after a certain time right
when they get to the line the mic is
shut off it's shot by the NFL it's not
shut off by like honor System so they
can't and then so a silent count would
be like a regular account would be like
they'll say like in cliche terms Hut or
like hike or whatever oh they have blue
42 you know blue 75 uh what Peyton
Manning would do is called the mic who's
gonna Rush In And then he'll call all
these different plays he'll change the
play on the line but on a silent count
you can't do any of that and so as soon
as you step up
um someone will get a signal and
everyone won't see the signal and
they'll know like oh two seconds later
or three seconds later or whatever the
ball's gonna be hyped could be the foot
yeah it could be anything wow and then
so so like it's interesting it comes up
now it's always been like that even when
we were at the Coliseum so the best game
was US versus the Chiefs I don't know if
you guys remember that game was like two
three seasons ago it was the highest
scoring Monday night game ever I don't
remember um it was crazy so I want to
say 55 to 60 of the fans were Chiefs and
then the rest of rams it was at the
Coliseum so it seats like 98 000 people
so every play there was cheering wow it
was the most unique experience I've ever
took for a football game because usually
it's just like you're you're on a home
team so when a good play uh happens for
the home team everyone's cheering but
then when the other team something good
happens no one's cheering but this game
there was cheering throughout and that's
kind of how it felt last night does it
make it more fun that there's like it's
just that much when it's a fun game like
the Chiefs game was fun because it was
it was just back and forth touchdown
touchdown touchdown so it was fun but
like last night was horrible because
like I had fun was this was it a
Slaughter
it didn't start that way it didn't start
that way but then it got to become that
way but so like when it was kind of like
even when I say even it was seven seven
ten ten yeah like at that point like if
we're on offense and something good
happens there's cheering and then with a
defense something good happens the Bills
fans are cheering us like so it get at
that point it gets a little depressing
because it's like I wish there was more
Rams Fans but it's LA and so I expect it
because you hear yeah and people's
attitudes are like dude and you guys
abandoned the city like you went to St
Louis for [ __ ] three decades right
yeah yeah so then I think there's a
little bit of hate from that but then I
think maybe the criticism right now is
because I didn't know well I've been to
I went to um a Chargers game and
obviously that's gonna be nobody gives a
[ __ ] about the LH driver right so like
you know when basically it was all Green
Bay fans there was Green Bay versus the
Chargers it's all green made fans it was
a home team game for the Packers but
with you guys you just hung a banner so
I think the there was a thought that
maybe more La citizens have come around
on you guys and I've seen a lot of
newmarkets for sure but maybe not yet
huh you know I think it's because
um ticket prices are so high because we
have to pay a personal seat license oh
the [ __ ] is that yeah so basically you
pay like anywhere from I don't know what
the cheapest is right now but let's just
say it's three thousand dollars all the
way up to like a hundred thousand
dollars okay
that's for the opportunity to buy like
tickets so you buy them by the seat now
they try to sell you on does that go
towards the actual season ticket or no
that's just the separate it's a separate
oh what a scam so then like if you're on
let's say the 20 yard line it's like 15
grand to 20 grand so if you get two
seats and it's 15 you have to pay 30 000
and then you have to also buy the
tickets the season tickets oh because
they're just only selling to the
celebrities and the millionaires in La
for the for the expensive ones you got
to be obviously gonna be pretty wealthy
a lot of people take loans out to do
this I don't know why but geez wow
because there's a hundred thousand
dollar seats they're club seats they're
cushioned and they're nice free food
free drink and then you get tickets to
every event at Sofi oh that's right oh
that's pretty cool to me that's worth it
if you're making a hundred thousand a
month let's say I I to me personally
that's worth a one month salary because
you get because they're gonna do the
final four there you know obviously BTS
was there
any big sporting event concert event you
those are your seats that's sweet it's
free food free drink so to you it's
worth a one month salary whether you
make 100 Grand or five grand or three no
no if I was making 100 Grand a month
yeah I would think it's worth it uh uh
one month salary but if I was making
like let's say 500 000 a year I mean I
don't know can you put someone else in
those seats if you were like whining and
dining you can you can do whatever you
want with this you can sell them and all
that
um but yeah so because and the people
don't do math I did the math you can't
make your money back so for me or my
seats I I'd have to do eight seasons not
going to one single game and hopefully
be able to charge 30 to 40 percent more
than the face value of the ticket to
make my money my personality license
back which I'm not gonna do that well
it's gonna be hard because you guys suck
so much ass now
who's going to want to watch those Rings
unless you're already doing that then
yeah it tastes good it tastes good but
yeah I mean I'm just glad we won the
Super Bowl last year yeah because I'm
riding that wave does this take away
from that Super Bowl win like because I
think a lot of fans now are saying like
you guys are kind of maybe the worst
Champions because you guys only beat the
Bengals and like so I think a lot of
people are just kind of questioning that
whole win though I mean a lot of people
are just Steve yeah those are just me
and my family chat
you know for me it's like okay every see
every after every Super Bowl the next
season one of those teams don't make the
playoffs yeah it's happened I think I
don't know if it's the whole entire
history of the NFL but it's happened
quite often
I just don't want to be that team yeah
as long as like we make the playoffs
I'm fine but if we don't make the
playoffs like it's a bad look I'm just
gonna look at all my clothes that says
Super Bowl champs did they change out
players what happened well cam makers uh
didn't show up for the game last night I
mean he was in pads but he didn't yeah
we have no running game
um they they cut
um one of my favorite players Robert
Woods USC wide receiver all USC why do
they cut them he is ACL injury yeah so
like that that felt so yeah Rams kind of
follows I think that the way Patriots do
things as soon as they show a little bit
decline they're gonna cut them they're
gonna get out and I and I get it but at
the same time it's like that sucks on
Alan Robinson
one catch I I agree yeah this is where I
feel like Robert Woods would have yeah
yeah because Robert Woods is a you know
I followed him from USC he's a
sure-handed receiver he blocks well he
runs great routes he's gonna get open
and he's he's a great dude um what is it
um he takes a lot of pressure away from
Cooper cup because now they both they
have to watch both of them he's still
bowled out last night yeah he did well
what are your thoughts so Bobby uh
didn't barbecues go to the Titans
where'd he go do you remember Robert
Woods I don't remember the thing I think
it's a title you cheer for Taylor rap
you know I've got we got a fellow Asian
brother on the field Katie tatara fellow
comedian he's half Japanese half white
yeah
he is a huge Taylor rap fan and he wants
him to do well just he's like and he and
his thing is I wanna I wanna protect the
half asian Legacy type thing
doing it for The Hoppers
yeah but he's not LA Rams yeah in La I
I'm I'm a fan of uh rap I liked him
before I knew he was half asian yeah you
know I think he needs to Market that
better personally speaking but I got
some more Asian tattoos I saw how would
you Market him better like I put a
hamburger in our sushi so it says Taylor
half asian wrap on Instagram I don't
know okay
Taylor Taylor lettuce wrap I don't know
something you know something fun but
yeah I think um I think it's great like
anytime Asians in the NFL I don't care
what team they're on that's a big deal
it's a big deal like I mean there's
stories of do you guys remember Eugene
Chung he came out of Virginia Tech went
to the Patriots that's right and he was
like one of the top left tackles in the
league and allegedly Parcells didn't
like him because he was Asian that's the
word who knows there's that one
Vietnamese Dude too Back In The Wind
that win yeah he's a linebacker Cowboys
yeah and then there was the biggest
Vietnamese do I ever seen what about my
Manti Teo you consider him Asian did you
guys watch the documentary I didn't get
to see it yet I saw clips though it's so
freaking good it smells crazy it's sad
the whole thing is are you guys familiar
it's really unfortunate he's the one
that catfish right yeah yeah big time
and he's on the Chargers that was a
rough rough life for him rough life you
guys have to watch the documentary it's
it is the most eye-opening thing about
catfishing you could watch and he and it
sucks because the girl that catfished
him or the guy that well the guy that
Captain watch it
initially when he was a kid he was
initially a guy now it's a transgender
woman but when when he got catfished he
got catfished by like the number one
pound-for-pound catfisher in the game oh
this person catfished the [ __ ] out of
him yeah that person deserves an Academy
Award all the worst [ __ ] you could do in
a catfish procedure
done what do you mean he's just watch it
I don't want to spoil it but yeah I
heard he was so good that he would face
time with the wig on foreign
[Music]
[Music]